This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When you send a letter to the President, it first passes through the office of presidential correspondence. The office was started under President McKinley in 1897, who had been receiving about 100 letters per day. By the time Herbert Hoover was President, that number had gone up to about 800 letters per day. Today, the President of the United States gets tens of thousands of letters, parcels, and emails every day.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。当你给总统写信时，它首先会经过总统联络办公室。这个办公室成立于1897年麦金利总统任内，当时他每天大约收到100封信。到了赫伯特·胡佛担任总统时，这个数字上升到每天大约800封。如今，美国总统每天都会收到数万封信件、包裹和电子邮件。
Matt President, as we produce this story, is still Barack Obama. Dear Mr. President. Dear Mr. President. Dear Mr. President. We met once. You came to my hometown of Tuscalo, and I was writing each day in regards
马特总统，在我们制作这个故事时，依然是巴拉克·奥巴马。亲爱的总统先生。亲爱的总统先生。亲爱的总统先生。我们见过一次面。你来到了我的家乡图斯卡洛，我每天都在写信，关于
to our relationship with Canada. And if you're one of those letter writers, you must imagine that the odds of the president actually reading your letter are pretty slim. That's Jacob Brogan, a writer for Slate.com and host of Working, a Slate podcast. And you'd be right, those chances are pretty slim. People often begin with a reflection on, I know no one will read this. I mean, that is a really common open. But someone does read your letter or email. And sometimes that person is Fiona Reeves,
我们与加拿大的关系。如果你是那些写信人之一，你一定觉得总统真的读到你的信的几率微乎其微。那是雅各布·布罗根，Slate.com的撰稿人兼Slate播客《Working》的主持人。你是对的，这些几率确实微乎其微。人们通常会以这样的反思开始：我知道没有人会读这个。我的意思是，这是一个非常常见的开场。但确实有人会读你的信或电子邮件。有时那个人是菲奥娜·里维斯，
Director of Presidential Correspondence at the White House. We are the office that handles all the incoming correspondence from regular people to the president and the White House. So we're a group of small offices made up of 45 staffers, 35 interns, and about 300 volunteers who come and go. Every day, Fiona and this small army of people read through thousands upon thousands of letters addressed to the president. President Obama has requested that 10 letters be passed on to him to read every night, and its fjowness job to decide which 10 it will be. The president has asked since day one to read 10 letters from regular people that represent
白宫总统联络办公室主任。我们这个办公室负责处理普通人发给总统和白宫的所有来信。所以我们是一群由45名职员、35名实习生以及大约300名来来往往的志愿者组成的小型办公团队。每天，菲奥娜和这支小小的队伍都要审阅成千上万封写给总统的信。奥巴马总统要求每晚递交10封信给他阅读，而菲奥娜的工作就是决定将是哪10封。总统从第一天起就要求阅读来自普通人的10封信，这些信代表了
what's coming in. These letters, I think, do more to keep me in touch with what's happening around the country than just about anything else. That's a clip from a 2009 video put out by the White House. Some of them are funny, some of them are angry. A lot of them are sad or frustrated about their current situation. Sometimes people reach out about being fired, or when they're down to their last scraps of savings,
信件的内容。我认为，这些信件比其他任何事情都更能让我与全国各地发生的事情保持联系。这是白宫2009年发布的一段视频中的片段。其中一些很有趣，一些很愤怒。许多人对他们目前的处境感到悲伤或沮丧。有时人们会诉说自己失业了，或者当他们只剩下最后一点积蓄时，
or their concerns about gun violence or climate change. So a lot of the stories are heartbreaking. People who work hard, a lot of times they'll say, I've never written to a president before, I'm not looking for a handout. All I want is just a fair shake. And it ends up being a powerful motivator for me. You know, it is crazy to think that you are holding this piece of paper that was in the person's hand
或者他们对枪支暴力或气候变化的担忧。因此，许多故事都令人心碎。努力工作的人们，很多时候他们会说，我以前从未给总统写过信，我不是在寻找施舍。我只想要一个公平的机会。这最终成为我强烈的动力。你知道，一想到你手里拿着这张纸，而这是当事人在向他们的政府求助时拿在手里的，
when they were reaching out to their government. And it is crazy to think that the president holds those pieces of paper. Of course, these days, letters don't always arrive on paper. Fiona and her staff also have to sort through all the emails that come in through the White House's web form at whitehouse.gov slash contact. Truth is, we're an email office for the most part, but we have a room that really looks like what you think of as male at the White House.
而总统也拿着这些纸，这真是太疯狂了。当然，如今信件并不总是以纸质形式到达。菲奥娜和她的团队还必须筛选通过白宫网页表单whitehouse.gov/contact进入的所有电子邮件。事实上，我们主要是一个电子邮件办公室，但我们有一个房间，看起来真的很像你想象中的白宫邮件室。
It talks to some boxes of male and shelves of topics and lists of what kind of agencies. Fiona works in the executive office building, located just west of the White House. We are scattered throughout this building and whichever rooms happen to be available. I can tell you we are tightly packed here. We sit very close together. And the staff sitting side by side in the Office of Presidential Correspondence carries on an old tradition of opening, reading, and sorting letters for the president. I would say our paper processing system cannot be very different than it was a hundred years ago.
它与几箱邮件、一排排主题架子以及关于哪些机构的列表对话。菲奥娜在位于白宫正西侧的行政办公大楼工作。我们分散在这栋楼的各个房间里，只要有空房间就行。我可以告诉你，我们这里挤得满满当当的。我们坐得很近。总统联络办公室里并肩而坐的工作人员延续了一项古老的传统：为总统拆信、阅读和分类信件。我想说，我们的纸质处理系统与一百年前没有太大区别。
Before letters arrive at the White House, they go through a screening process. So when the office of presidential correspondence receives them, they've already been opened by Secret Service, you know, checking for anthrax or explosives. Paper letters are clipped to the envelopes they arrived in. But then it's up to the staff and interns and volunteers to dig through the letters and emails and figure out which ones to pass up the chain to Fiona. How many do you have to read a day?
在信件到达白宫之前，它们要经过筛选过程。因此，当总统联络办公室收到它们时，特勤局已经打开过它们了，你知道的，是为了检查炭疽或爆炸物。纸质信件会别在它们寄来时的信封上。但接下来就要靠员工、实习生和志愿者去翻阅信件和电子邮件，并弄清楚哪些信件要向上传递给菲奥娜。你一天必须读多少？
It varies depending on the day, but I would say on a general day the number that gets sort of passed to me can be from 200, 400 emails and letters. And you read that many emails and letters every day, roughly? Every day that the president is in town, he only gets the 10 letters a day when he's in Washington. Fiona and her team are looking for a range of opinions and styles that express what Americans are thinking about. We want to give him male that is representative of incoming male that is geographically diverse. We also look for different writing styles and different levels of writing and ways of communicating. The office also puts some thought into where the president is heading in the coming weeks and what issues he'll be discussing. To try to maybe make him better equipped
这取决于具体哪一天，但我想说，在一般的一天里，传到我这里的邮件和信件数量大约在200到400封之间。你每天大致要读那么多邮件和信件？在总统在城的每一天，他只有在华盛顿的时候每天才看10封信。菲奥娜和她的团队在寻找能够表达美国人想法的各种观点和风格。我们希望给他提供能够代表来信、且具有地域多样性的邮件。我们也在寻找不同的写作风格、不同的写作水平以及沟通方式。办公室还会考虑总统在未来几周的去向以及他将讨论哪些议题。
to spend time in that community, or to discuss an issue that maybe he doesn't have or like a personal perspective on, sort of a way of giving him more advisors. And the letters don't just inform and influence the president. Fiona makes sure the entire White House gets a chance to see what people are writing and about. Each day, our team does something with the help of volunteers called a random daily sample.
试图让他做好更充分的准备，以便在那个社区花时间，或者讨论一个他可能没有或者不太了解个人看法的议题，这有点像是为他提供更多顾问的一种方式。这些信件不仅能通报和影响总统。菲奥娜还要确保整个白宫都有机会看到人们在写些什么以及他们在写什么。每天，我们的团队在志愿者的帮助下做一件事，叫做随机日常样本。
So we look at all the email that just came in and put together a list of topics and four in a post. And we circulate that list throughout the White House to a pretty broad distribution group to give folks a sense of what the American people are saying that day. They also put together a word cloud that shows the most commonly used terms across all forms of communication. The biggest word is help because generally when you're reaching out to your government, you are looking for help with the issue that matters most to you. There are times though, like you can see right now, the biggest word is gun, where there's a conversation
因此，我们查看刚刚进来的所有电子邮件，整理出一个主题列表并在帖子里发布四个。我们在白宫内部相当广泛的分发群体中传阅该列表，让大家了解那天美国人民在说些什么。他们还会制作一个词云，显示所有交流形式中最常用的术语。最大的词是“帮助”，因为通常当你向政府求助时，你是在寻求对你最重要的问题的帮助。不过有时，就像你现在看到的，最大的词是“枪”，这时讨论
that has risen above every other topic. So in that case, Fiona will make sure the president gets a letter about guns. But when we do that, we make sure he sees both sides and we think a lot about the order in which things are given to him, you know, how you read sides and we think a lot about the order in which things are given to him. You know, how you read something and I think affects the way it hits you. And after Fiona chooses the ten letters, she hands them off to someone who scans them
已经超越了所有其他话题。所以在这种情况下，菲奥娜会确保总统收到一封关于枪支的信。但当我们这样做时，我们会确保他看到双方的观点，并且我们对给她东西的顺序考虑了很多，你知道的，你是如何阅读双方观点的，我们对递送事物的顺序考虑了很多。你知道，你阅读事物的方式我想会影响它给你的冲击。在菲奥娜挑选出这10封信后，她将它们交给了扫描人员，
and then hands them to the person who puts together the president's briefing book. So each night he takes home sort of a homework binder and it has information on what he'll be doing the next day. And every night includes the 10 constituent letters. Unlike almost everything else that reaches the president, these letters have not been fact-jector committee reviewed. There's some of the most direct communication he receives. When people are writing a memo to the president, you know, if they are touching on a policy topic,
然后交给负责整理总统简报本的人。因此，他每天晚上带回家一个类似家庭作业的文件夹，里面有关于他第二天要做什么的信息。每天晚上都包括这10封选自选民的信。几乎所有其他到达总统手里的东西都不同，这些信件没有经过事实核查员或委员会的审查。这是他收到的最直接的交流之一。当人们给总统写备忘录时，你知道，如果他们触及某个政策话题，
then everyone who has a hand in that or who may have information to add that could add value kind of takes a look at it and adds their two cents. And so by the time the president sees it, it has gone through so many eyes, but our correspondence is really like someone sits down at their kitchen table and they send in a piece of their mind. And then that is basically two sets of eyes in the White House. It's this volunteer who thought, hey, the president should read this. And then it's me saying, like, yeah, I agree with that.
那么所有参与其中或可能提供有价值信息的补充信息的人都会看一看并发表他们的两分钱见解。因此，当总统看到它时，它已经经过了无数双眼睛，但我们的信件真的就像某人坐在厨房桌旁，送出了他们内心的想法。然后，白宫里基本上只有两双眼睛。一个是认为“嘿，总统应该读这个”的志愿者。然后是我说：“是的，我同意这一点。”
And because these letters are so direct and unfiltered, a lot of them are pretty intense and deeply personal. Our office deals a lot in emotion and empathy because we are absorbing so much of what people hope and fear and what they're expressing to both the president of the United States but also Barack Obama and the way they see themselves in Barack Obama and that I think makes our workplace quite an emotional one. A lot of people write about where they're writing from or what time they're writing.
由于这些信件非常直接且未经过滤，其中许多都相当强烈且非常个人化。我们的办公室处理了大量的悲喜情感和同理心，因为我们吸收了人们的许多希望与恐惧，以及他们向美国总统乃至巴拉克·奥巴马表达的内容，以及他们在巴拉克·奥巴马身上看到自己的方式，我认为这使我们的工作场所充满了情感。许多人写下他们写作的地点或写作的时间。
You know, I'm staying up late at night because I can't stop thinking about this. I was sort of open that transports you immediately into what are they gonna say? Or, you know, from my kitchen window, I can see these mountains that we call, and then you're like in that person's kitchen with them. We also recently have seen more and more letters
你知道，我深夜不睡觉，因为我一直在想这个。我有点开放，这会立刻把你带入：他们会说什么？或者，你知道，从我的厨房窗户，我可以看到我们称之为的这些山，然后你就好像和那个人一起在他们的厨房里。我们最近也越来越多地看到
that begin with something like, I've been meaning to write this for seven years. I think, yeah, as the days dwindle down, we're getting a lot of under the wire. Here's what I've been meaning to tell you. There was one letter that went to the president yesterday from a man who wrote that he feels like because of the presence or the pervasive nature
以诸如“我一直想写这个已经七年了”之类的开头。我想，是的，随着日子一天天减少，我们收到了很多压线的信息。这是我一直想对你说的。昨天有一封信送到了总统手里，是一个男人写的，他写道，他觉得由于美国枪支暴力的存在或普遍存在，尽管他在美国是个同性恋者，但他觉得他宁愿住在不承认同性婚姻的地方，也不愿死在枪口之下，这是他的一种，嗯，他的角度。我们在昨晚刚刚把它交给了总统，所以我不知道他读到它时受到的冲击是怎样的，但当它击中我时，我感触很深。有没有，有没有任何一封信是有趣的？它们很有趣，那是事情的另一面。是的。
of gun violence in the US, despite being a gay man in the United States felt like he would rather live somewhere that didn't recognize same-sex marriage than a place where he could be discriminated against at the end of a gun, of sort of his, um, his angle there. And we just gave out to the President last night so I don't know how that hit him when he read it, but when it hit me, it hit me hard. Are there any, are there any of them ever that are funny They're funny that are the kind of the other side of things. Yeah.
我们收到了一些有趣的信。我随身携带的一封来自一个正在竞选她初中班级班长的年轻女性。她写信是想寻求一些演讲写作方面的建议。奥巴马总统实际上回复了那封信。他的建议是：演讲要简短。其中一些他是亲笔回复的。有些他写了一些类似于，
We get some funny letters. One that I have with me is from a young woman who was running for a class president of her junior class. And she wrote in that she wanted some speech writing advice. President Obama actually responded to that letter. His advice, keep speeches short. And some of them he responds to by hand. Some of them he writes something like,
尼尔，你能查一下这个吗？这有点像要求他团队里的人看一看。而在其他信件上，他写了回复，但随后写了一些起草指导。白宫有一个作家团队，他们详细阐述总统的便签并将其转化为信件，然后交回给总统签名。由于多年来他亲自回复了如此多的信件，作家们通常对他的声音有很好的把握。而且往往他的页边批注是如此广泛，他实际上是在亲自回复这封信。
Neil, can you look into this? That is sort of to ask someone on his team to take a look at it. And on others, he writes reply, but then he writes sort of some drafting guidance. The White House has a team of writers who elaborate on the president's notes and turn them into letters, which they then hand back for the president to sign. And because he's responded personally to so many letters over the years, the writers often have a really good sense of his voice. And often his margin notes are so extensive, he's practically responding to the letter himself.
我们最终充其量更像是打字员而不是作家。当总统确实参与到信件中时，无论是通过回复还是通过发出参加白宫活动的邀请，或者以公开的方式突出某封特定的信件，白宫通常会与作者取得联系。有时，菲奥娜会成为打通那个电话的人。事实是，我们并不总是
We end up serving as really more of typists than writers. When the president does engage with the letter, whether by replying or by extending an invitation to a White House event, or to highlight a specific letter in a public way, the White House usually gets in touch with the author. Sometimes, Fiona gets to be the one to make that phone call. And the truth is, we don't always
需要打那些电话。我们打它们是因为它们真的很鼓舞人心。当有人对巴拉克·奥巴马做出如此疯狂的长距离尝试，写下一些东西并将其投入邮箱时，那是多么令人兴奋啊。当你打电话给他们时，人们会抓狂吗？有时人们会抓狂。我通常打这些电话，我的声音听起来比我实际感觉到的更严肃。
need to make those phone calls. We make them because they're really energizing. It's just so exciting when someone has taken this crazy long shot of writing something to Barack Obama and putting it in a mailbox. Do people flip out when you call them? Sometimes people flip out. I generally make those phone calls, and I sound sort of more serious than I feel when I
你知道，对于第一个电话，我说我是康，所以我必须确认你的地址，而在我的内心。我在想，你敢相信吗？菲奥娜的兴奋是显而易见的。她在这届政府呆了很长时间，这对她的生活发挥了巨大的作用。她在整理奥巴马的邮件时遇到了她的丈夫。这份工作对白宫和
make them. You know, I say I'm con for the first one and so I have to confirm your address when in my heart. I'm like, can you believe it? Fiona's excitement is palpable. She's been a part of this administration a long time and it's played a huge role in her life. She met her husband while they were sorting Obama's mail. And the job has had a real impact on the White House and the
在那里工作的人产生了真正的影。我认为它塑造了白宫推行的政策。我认为它也塑造了在这里工作的人。你知道，你禁不住会去想它。当我想到我们办公室的产物时。其一是我们拥有一支相当庞大的年轻人队伍，他们将继续做其他事情，并带着更广泛的视角继续前进。在某些情况下，对于那些他们不一定见过的人对政府的感受和期望，他们拥有非常深刻和个人化的视角。菲奥娜即将成为众多曾经穿梭于这个办公室的人之一，因为她的工作随着本届政府的结束而告一段落。你的下一步打算是什么？
people who work there. I think it shapes policies that the White House pursues. I think also it shapes the humans who work here. You know, you can't help but think about it. When I think about the outputs of our office. One is we have this pretty big team of young people who will go on to do other things and will go on with this much broader perspective. And in some cases, a very deep and personal perspective on what people who they haven't necessarily met feel and expect from their government. And Fiona is about to be one of those many people who have passed through the office because her job is ending with the administration. And what's next for you?
我不知道。你们在招人吗？我不知道。我真的不知道。我认为这是一个有趣的工作场所，因为这个机构已经存在了很长时间，工作是因为这个机构已经存在了很长时间，但你每隔四八年就会重新开始，所以当你准备离开时，你会觉得你刚刚弄懂了它并且做得很好。白宫将把“联系我们”表格开放到本届政府的最后一天，即1月19日。即使你在1月19日写信，它也可以送达奥巴马。他将在椭圆形办公室的最后一个晚上收到10封信。这篇文章的一个版本最初在Slate的《Working》播客中播出，作为关于
I don't know. Are you guys hiring? I have no idea. I have truly no idea. I think it's a funny place to work because the institution has existed for so long, work because the institution has existed for so long, but you begin again every four eight years and so then when you are getting ready to leave you feel like you've just sort of figured it out and are nailing it. The White House is keeping their contact us form open to the last day of the administration, January 19th. Even if you write a letter on January 19th, it can reach Obama. He'll be receiving 10 letters on his last night in the Oval Office. A version of this piece originally aired on Slate's Working Podcast as part of a series
白宫工作系列的一部分，由雅各布·罗根和米奇·卡珀制作。参与本期节目的99%隐形团队成员包括艾弗里·特罗布曼、谢里夫·尤塞夫和凯蒂·明格尔。还有库尔特·科尔斯特德、萨姆·格林斯潘、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、泰兰·马扎、德兰尼·霍尔和我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是位于旧金山91.7K ALW的项目，在美丽健康的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市广播街制作。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。
on jobs at the White House, produced by Jacob Rogan and Mickey Kapper. The 99% invisible team who worked on this episode includes Avery Troubleman, Sharif Useff, and Katie Mingle. With Kurt Colstead, Sam Greenspan Emmett Fitzgerald, Terran Mazza, Delaney Hall, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
你可以在推特上@我：罗曼·马尔斯，以及节目@99PI orc。我们也在Instagram和汤博乐上。但每天，我都阅读通过99pi.org上的联系页面发送的10条消息。你 本集节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI orc. We're on Instagram and Tumblr too. But every day, I read 10 messages sent through the contact page at 99pi.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.